Hey guys welcome back i'm nate with the king of random and today
We're going to make a fun device that makes bubble foam balloons that float into the air
similar devices are used to make floating foam shapes that serve as
Advertisements, but I really just think that they are fun to make and play with the purpose of today's video is to find an easy
Way to make this machine that can produce these foam flying balloons. Here's the materials
We're going to need for this project a flat pan
I find that straight walled pans work better than pie tins this was less than a dollar at Walmart
Some thin vinyl tubing I got this stuff for 15 cents per foot and about six feet is plenty a tank of helium
Which you can get at Walmart or most party stores for around 30 bucks
Bubble soap a glue gun and some extra glue sticks a lighter or torch and a couple of pins
Now that we have all of our parts and tools, let's get started first
Let's use our glue gun and use a little bit of hot glue to plug up one end of our vinyl tube
Now we've glued up the end of our tube, let's glue it to the center of our cake pan
Add some extra glue going over the top of the tube to help secure it permanently in place
In a spiral let's move out from the middle gluing down the tube all the way
Using extra glue secure the tube near the edge, and at least one more spot in the middle of the coil
Okay guys now that we've got our tube glued down in a spiral in the bottom of our pan
Let's add some small holes to make our bubbles first
Let's take our straight pin and heat the tip up using our lighter
Then we use the hot tip of the pin to poke holes in our vinyl tubing do this about every 3/4 inches along the tube
OK, we've taken our tube
And we filled it with a lot of tiny holes and now we want to test that all those holes work
Otherwise we're gonna
Get some lopsided foam balloons as the air comes out of one side
but not the other the easiest way to test if the holes are working is to fill your mouth with water and then blow the
water down through the tube
It'll create a tiny fountain from every hole in the tube and you'll be able to see which ones may have become clogged back up
If you see any without a jet of water coming out of them you need to heat your pin back up and melt a new
Hole all the holes in our tubes seem to be working
Well, which means our foam bubbler is complete?
And it's time to start adding bubble soap and making foam we actually don't want to use pure bubble soap
It's a little bit of a heavier liquid and so even with helium in it
It's heavy enough that it won't float very well, so what we actually want is about one part bubble soap and seven parts water
Gently stir the bubble soap in the water to get a nice even mixture
We want to make sure there's enough bubble solution to cover the vinyl tubing
But we don't want it to fill the pan there should be some exposed edge still
Now we need some helium the vinyl tube should fit snugly over the nozzle that comes attached to the helium tank
Just like that our foam bubbler is complete now. Let's take this outside and make some floating foam balloons at this point
We just undo the stopper on the tank press down on the valve and helium will start forming bubbles in our pan
There it is
Oh
I do find we get better and more consistent?
Results if we grow the bubbles out slowly instead of opening the valve as far as it will go I think by going slowly it
Allows time for the excess bubble fluid to drain off of the phone. That's forming, so it doesn't weigh it down
Oh broke free there we go
Now because all of the bubbles are full of helium as the tower grows it just sort of keeps itself straight up this lets you
Grow the tower taller and taller until too many bubbles pop, or it has enough lift that it pulls itself right off
Or you can still see the last 100
Wind wind has liberated the bubbles
Okay, I added more bubble solution into the pan
So there's more if it covering up the vinyl tubes and what appears to happen is that I have a lot smaller bubbles now
I'm not 100% sure if that's gonna be a good thing or a bad thing yet
I'm liking the look of this😆
There it goes there 😃
It goes it's like a big white caterpillar going up and all the tree caught it. I'm gonna try and free it I
Go they got let go hmmm, I think it lives there now
Sticking to my hand, but I think I'm gonna shake it off, and it's gonna take off into the air there it goes and
It's completely changed direction apparently
Be free little cloud
bubble balloon
Wow
There it goes there it goes
Launching off into the sky
That looks like a giant flavorless cheeto oh
It's cruising
I'm gonna try making some smaller ones
Sometimes right after you take it off
It's still kind of dripping extra bubble soap, so if you just give it a second. It'll start pulling more and more
Oh
Little heavy oh there you go
You can see as it starts dripping off some of the excess it will gain a little bit more altitude
It's alive
It does kind of look alive like it's just moving in the wind and it's just
Like a weird tentacle growing out of the cake pan
Tentacle cake it's a new kind of cake
What wind aah
It's stuck in the trees and powerlines right there
It's just bubbles so can you imagine how confused you would be if something like that just sort of like drifted into your yard
You'd have no idea what that was that'd be kind of weird
I'm gonna see what happens if I just push on the vowel as far as it'll go and give it like full power helium
All right that was a little anticlimactic. Wonder if our helium running low
Go go go go go
Guys this was great it was so cool to just watch those foam balloons launching up into the sky
This is a quick and easy build that you can do at home
and it's a ton of fun to play with I've got some crazy ideas about how to scale this up in the future including I
Want to try making a bubble pan that's several feet across a couple other things
I want to try are this helium that comes for filling balloons is actually not pure grade helium
It's helium mixed with about 20% air so I think we might get some better lift if we use some industrial-strength helium
and then of course I also want to try using hydrogen so we can make some foam balloons that will light on fire when you
Hit them with a flame there you have it now. You know how to make your very own foam balloon machine
Thank you for joining us for this project today, and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then
There's no wind in here. It's great. Just keep going
No, don't get stuck in the other
Be free, be free yes, no
You can get it touch the ceiling
If I have enough helium for that you can do it little foam Tower you can do it draw
Since it's like soap. Do you think it will clean the ceiling off a little bit?
Go go go your so close like an inch away. We've done it. We've done it. We're touching the ceiling
Hey guys I have seen your comments begging me to come back into the videos and although I can't do that right now
I really do appreciate how much you care even though you can't see me
I'm still very much a part of this channel and a part of these videos, and I still love you just as much